my name is bear Tarpley for two years I
was a telephony agent and case manager
at Universal Credit
there's old Looney Tunes cartoons where
it's Bugs Bunny or whoever in a boat and
holes keep springing up and they keep
plugging finger after finger into these
holes it's not the individual holes that
are the issue it's a bad boat and that
to me sort of sums up universal credit
of universal credit universal credit
universal credit we've rolled six
benefits into one from December 6
benefits will be merged into one the
Prime Minister promised to stand up for
families who are just managing you do
not under fund it as it goes in seems
like nobody knew what they were doing
very little getting people into work and
that is what Universal Credit is doing
the National Audit Office says Universal
Credit could end up costing more than
the system and replaces it's being used
to cut people's benefits the system is
not working and it really needs to be
rethought fundamentally people spoke I
listened that's universal credit from
the outside at least but this is the
story of what it's like behind the
closed doors of the system
when you apply for universal credit
there's three sort of steps that you
have to go through universal credit when
you make your claim you're eligible for
a new claim advanced within the fart is
different things your claim on the
journal it's where people will upload
evidence it's where we post them letters
bare topically spent two years working
inside Universal Credit he has an
encyclopedic knowledge of the system its
processes how claims would how people
get paid the winners and the losers you
can be good in the bath this is the
first time any universal credit agent
has spoken openly on camera and his
assessment is damning I think certainly
from a frontline position I wasn't
particularly confident the universal
credit was meeting that goal of helping
people in work and making them better
off based on their circumstances from
this call center in Grimsby
bayaud says changes to the system the
Curt daily but not necessarily for the
benefit of the claimant it was things
like making it easier for us to process
things or making it easier for us to end
a call sooner or changing who does what
job so that we can quickly get through
things that didn't seem to be a lot of
changes that were specifically there to
support claimants with particular
problems that were being raised so it
was all about getting them off the phone
as quickly as possible so there was
there is something called the deflection
script which is within your booth you
have a piece of paper that explains what
to do when someone calls in and the
first thing you do is ask them what
their call is about and based on that
you would tell them to do it online
write a message to their case manager in
their journal make the change themselves
and you would explain all of that even
if it's something that you could do
quite quickly over the phone even if
they've been waiting on hold for an hour
and 15 minutes and you were encouraged
to do everything in your power to get
them to hang up the phone and do that
online this is exactly how universal
credit is meant to work online to make
it simpler cheaper to run claimants have
to do a lot for themselves with very
little help
the problem is in 2015 the Treasury cut
a major element out of universal credit
within universal credit as with tax
credits there's an amount of money that
you get to earn before your tax credits
start
being reduced so it's similar to the
person allowance for tax one of the big
cuts that was made in the budget was
that that work allowance as it's called
was removed completely for some people
and was massively reduced for other
people and what that means is that for a
lot of working families particularly as
soon as they move onto universal credit
they will be worse off in work poverty
is already a massive problem for
millions new figures from the Joseph
Rowntree Foundation show that 4 million
workers are now locked in poverty that's
a rise of half a million in the last
five years
that's the highest rate in 20 years and
this is crucial
while employment is rising the number of
workers in poverty is rising at a faster
rate this is the opportunity for the
Chancellor to put that money back into
universal credit and show that he wants
to give that living stans's boost to 10
million parents and children who really
need to see a benefit from the
government
this is Mansfield in Nottingham sure
once supported by the coal industry is
now struggling with the lack of it 28
percent of children here live in poverty
universal credit rolled into town last
month it's just hard especially when
you're on your own you know you're
trying to balance everything that's
already hard anyway there's a struggle
Sam fragile II is a working single mum
what she earns doesn't cover what she
needs to live and she's worried that
universal credit could make her worse
off it made me feel like I was failing
even though I was trying my best living
day-to-day like this do you think that's
acceptable in 21st century now shouldn't
a nobody like nobody struggle in this
day and age and you couldn't have
predicted what was about to happen no
not at all
a few months ago Sam had to suddenly
quit work and go off sick the next time
I saw her I'd find out why universal
credit is calculated on a monthly basis
it's done based on what they call an
assessment period which for everybody is
slightly different but it's always a
one-month period based on one you made
your claim what date you made your play
off it doesn't always mirror the way
that people are paid from work or other
benefits that they're receiving or any
other income that they're receiving or
the way that their lives are structured
and because of the way that Universal
Credit is in theory constantly based on
your real-time circumstances that can
sometimes mean that for reasons that
claimants don't always understand
suddenly they don't get a payment one
month because we say that they've
learned too much and that's catching a
lot of people out about half an hour
north of Mansfield is Bassett law that
Sherwood Forest divides the two places a
year ago Universal Credit was ruled out
there and ever since then there have
been huge problems most of the people
who come into this food bank are in work
and on universal credit what we now see
em with people that are on universal
credit is the constant changes to those
payments if they have any changes in
circumstances they have to put it on
their journal and it affects the
payments the main causes are people that
are mostly employee zero hour contracts
minimum wage can't make ends meet it's
you know rising food costs fuel costs
everything that goes with it working
families yeah your new families but some
people might say you've got to learn the
system it's it's you can't just sit back
and expect the system to support you if
you need to get online you get online if
you need to learn the system learn the
system you know you're gonna get
sanctioned avoid it
yes sir is that fair no I don't think
it's fair I think in a general picture
of normal living life yes but for
chaotic lives they may not have access
to the Internet they may not have access
to a computer
they may not have the ability the IT
skills they may not have an online bank
account never use an online bank account
it's all about education some bigger
bigger spectrum as an agent you would
receive calls from people who were in a
vulnerable situation who were at wit's
end trying to figure out what was
happening with their payments people who
had gotten conflicting answers and that
would be in a variety of forms of people
being distressed crying shouting
insisting on speaking to a manager daily
monthly weekly in some form I would I
would say I think daily you would you
would have you would have an angry
customer you would have an upset
customer you would have someone who was
vulnerable someone who was distressed in
in some way and what's the system
designed do you say to support those
people who were ringing up going I
cannot understand what I'm doing I I
don't think enough was done to support
people who were in those positions he
was a single parent he raised me and my
sister on his own that's how the whole
benefits system started for him Brian
Bailey was born with the foot deformity
in May he was told he would lose his
disability benefit and move on to
universal credit he was suffering panic
attacks he didn't wanna go to his
appointments it was crying he was
worried about money he was worried about
losing his flat it's very rare you could
get through touching speak to a human
being on July the 17th on the day he was
due to attend an appointment with the
universal credit manager Brian locked
himself in his house went up to his
bedroom and took his own life he was 59
I know it's hard to say for sure but do
you think that the struggles he had with
universal credit contributed to what he
did he was under a lot of pressure from
the benefits agency he was getting
constant letters constant text messages
checking journal the appointments having
to go in having to see the
wait coach he was just getting fed up he
just said it was like a merry-go-round
but he couldn't get off towards the end
of my time there there were stand up
meetings which were once a day and there
were team meetings which were once a
week and those would tend to be when
your manager would reveal there was
going to be a change either people were
moving teams or you were going to change
jobs slightly or we were going to start
doing this and stop doing that and say
this when you're speaking to claimants
don't say this when you're speaking to
claimants and that could change day to
day week to week month to month so
rapidly changing environment that you
have to work in understand and
communicate to claimants yes it was it
was constantly changing and it was very
difficult to stay on top of that as an
agent never mind
also having to communicate that to
people claiming the Department for Work
and Pensions said claims of a deflection
script were completely false but out of
that when handling a query call agents
may use aids to help them effectively
process cases including directing
claimants online in relation to their
claim a DWP spokesperson said we take
the training of our call handling staff
extremely seriously to ensure they are
prepared to handle a range of inquiries
regardless of how long they might take
there is no policy to get callers off
the phones there are a lot of reasons
why the whole benefit system needs to
work for some it's a safety net remember
Sam
she's been on sick leave since May I
wanted to catch up with her at home the
thing about Sam is she's not sick it's
her son Jacob who's sick in May he was
diagnosed with bone cancer and even
though he was given only a 30% chance of
survival Sam was told she'd have to wait
three months for Disability Living
Allowance
the family ended up turning to a food
bank
I think is to school stem there's no
support well we weren't given a choice
in this you know we didn't ask for their
Jacob didn't you know we didn't do
anything wrong for it to happen towards
a but was left in that circumstance we
were just start to get on with it and
there should be a support network out
there that that helps in that
circumstance and in a crisis because
that's it was a crisis in it within a
week our family got turned upside down
Universal Credit is the biggest change
to the welfare system in a generation in
response to growing criticisms the
Department for Work and Pensions says it
will slow down the rollout of Universal
Credit but the scale of opposition is
growing one of the most powerful
committees in Parliament the Public
Accounts Committee says Universal Credit
is causing unacceptable hardship to
claimants and in addition to that the
department has been accused of
persistently dismissing concerns raised
by those on the front line if your
family reliant on zero-hour contracts
mum might be on maternity leave dad
doesn't know how many or mom doesn't
know how many hours she's getting it
from week to next yeah they are the
victims in all yes yes they're the ones
that's working really hard to keep that
family unit together
the Prime Minister says work should pay
yeah what work should pay and that you
know it they're working really really
hard and some of them are falling in the
first hurdle and it's really sad to
watch because they are out there working
in its current form Universal Credit
would leave more than three million
families worse off than they are under
the old tax credit system and that was
never the intention of universal credit
it was always supposed to improve living
standards to make working more
worthwhile for people I think the whole
system's chaotic I rarely do the don't
point you in the right direction I don't
think they give you enough support I
don't think there's enough one-on-one
human interaction
there's old Looney Tunes cartoon
where it's Bugs Bunny or whoever in a
boat and holes keep springing up and
they keep plugging finger after finger
into these holes it's not the individual
holes that are the issue it's a bad boat
and that to me sort of sums up universal
credit
[Music]